[Música]
Bienvenidos a un nuevo episodio de
boleto de vuelta que en esta ocasión nos
lleva a Irak 20 años después de la
guerra uno de los episodios de mayor
división en el panorama Internacional de
la historia reciente el 20 de marzo de
2003 en el marco de la guerra contra el
terrorismo Estados Unidos y sus aliados
decidieron invadir Irak según ellos
Sadam hussein el presidente iraquí de
aquella época acusado por Washington de
estar relacionado con la red terrorista
al qaeda y por posesión de armas de
destrucción masivas lanzaron la
operación militar Irak freedom sin la
autorización del Consejo de Seguridad y
tampoco del apoyo de Francia en tan solo
tres semanas Bagdad cayó bajo los
bombardeos de la coalición y cinco días
más tarde fue tic rit la ciudad natal de
Sadam hussein durante su dictadura hizo
de dicha aglomeración en ese entonces
poco conocida una de las más bellas país
la caída de la ciudad simboliza entonces
en alguna medida la del régimen cuyo
final fue definitivo unos cuantos meses
más tarde con el arresto del dictador y
su ejecución 20 años más tarde que ha
sido de TIC Rick después de estos
acontecimientos Cuál es la situación
actual de sus habitantes Esta es la
historia
[Música]
the Creed en el corazón de Irak tan solo
140.000 habitantes pero un nombre que
resuena funestamente en numerosos
iraquíes fue aquí que Sadam husein nació
en 1937
más Precisamente en un pueblo cerca a la
ciudad
al aulla
es hacia allá que nos dirigimos hoy a la
entrada del pueblo un comité de acogida
nos prohíbe El Paso
Qué haces aquí están aquí para visitar
la tumba de Sadam es eso
no solo queremos filmar el pueblo es un
lugar militar está prohibido estar aquí
deben irse inmediatamente perfecto no
hay problema tan solo díganos a dónde
dirigirnos para pedir una autorización
está prohibido deme los papeles de su
vehículo
desde hace años al aulla es un pueblo
fantasma inaccesible
aquí no es seguro váyanse Por qué no es
seguro no hay nadie
no es seguro es todo llamen a nuestro
superiores en Bagdad por favor
Los guardianes del pueblo no pertenecen
ni al ejército ni a la policía
pertenecen a una facción paramilitar
cercana a Irán el ex enemigo de San José
No hay forma de negociar debemos irnos
a la ciudad de
es mejor no acercarse
allá las fuerzas instalaron bloques de
cemento alrededor y cuarteles para
vigilar los habitantes fueron
desplazados hace tiempo y los grupos
armados les prohíben regresar
y hace parte de los grandes apellidos de
tikrill proviene de una familia muy
influyente lucha desde hace años para
que los antiguos habitantes tengan
acceso al pueblo Miren la distancia
entre la hoja y tigrid unos cuantos
kilómetros es absurdo los habitantes
están autorizados a regresar a ti pero
no a su pueblo
marwan es portavoz del Consejo de las
tribus locales
esta asamblea se reúne cada mes para
hablar sobre asuntos políticos
el caso de laulla hace parte de los
expedientes sobre la mesa desde hace
años
Hola a todos
gracias por estar presentes hoy y
debemos abordar muchos temas
primero la situación general de Irak
de los bloqueos políticos etcétera
pero también la situación de los
desplazados Y en especial ya saben los
de a la olla
sepan que la semana pasada visitamos una
serie de ministerios que tienen entre
sus competencias el asunto de los
desplazados y planteamos el problema de
los de la región de todas las
localidades a la hoja incluido vaciado
de sus habitantes
en la sala un miembro de la tribu álbum
asir de la que hacía partes Adam hussein
toma la palabra
hay que decirlo todo esto es un asunto
privado es algo político porque es el
lugar de nacimiento del presidente Sam
husein
no representa nada más es insignificante
para ellos nos reunimos con el
presidente de la república
el Primer Ministro la más pequeña
entidad y que obtuvimos
nada
actualmente tan solo 280 familias de
esta tribu siguen viviendo en ticrito
eran 5000 en el 2003 hacia hayan probado
que no jugaron ningún papel en las
estructuras del Antiguo régimen estos
hombres y mujeres padecen según ellos
sus orígenes 20 años después
el problema es que las fuerzas que
dominan el terreno son
multidireccionales y ello complica las
conversaciones el ejército es el
ejército la policía es el Ministerio del
interior pero las fuerzas de
movilización popular están bajo
distintas órdenes si se tiene una
respuesta positiva de un lado otros
pueden anular la decisión
Tratamos de contactar a las facciones
armadas solo el grupo hyundalimán los
Soldados del imam a cargo de una parte
de tigrid aceptaron reunirse con
nosotros
la cita tuvo lugar en el centro en los
antiguos Palacios de sadán con la
promesa de tener acceso al aulla después
pertenecemos a las fuerzas de
movilización popular y estuvimos entre
los primeros que ingresamos a la
provincia de tigrid en 2015 tras la
liberación frente a daesh
todos estos hombres son chiítas y no son
de esta región de mayorías unita primero
quieren conducirnos a uno de los
palacios donde el daesh cometió una de
las peores extracciones antes de la
liberación de la ciudad porque para
ellos el crimen fue organizado por
antiguos fieles de Sadam hussein sigue
habiendo mucha gente a favor de Sadam
hussein en la región Y esa gente
aprovechó mucho el partido baat en
aquella época
Entonces les gustaría que regresaran al
poder
muchos adhirieron entonces a al qaeda y
luego a daesh para vengar a Sadam
hussein y el partido
en este Palacio que pertenecía a Sadam
hussein tuvo lugar la masacre de España
en junio de 2014 entre 1000 y 1700
soldados chiítas desarmados de la base
aérea de Space fueron ejecutados con
frialdad los jóvenes soldados no eran de
aquí y los traidores lo eran expandieron
el terror los manipularon diciéndoles
que salieran de su base y que todo
estaría bien cuando en realidad iban a
dirigirse hacia la muerte sí los
traidores eran fieles de Sadam y del
estado islámico esa masacre hace parte
de las razones por las cuales estos
grupos rechazan el regreso de los
habitantes de alaia según nuestras
informaciones muchos miembros de la
tribu de Sadam husein habrían
efectivamente participado en esa masacre
pero la gran mayoría de los asesinos
harían parte de otra tribu de la región
y nada permite probar que este baño de
sangre fue organizado para vengar al
antiguo dictador en el momento de la
liberación de tikrith en el 2015 estas
facciones chiítas fueron acusadas de
sectarismo espero que todos estos
Palacios se vuelvan santuarios para las
familias chiguitas de los mártires
hacer de un lugar de peregrinación hacia
sadán es lo que estos grupos armados
tratan de evitar a toda Costa la
verdadera razón de esta seguridad
reforzada en efecto el Antiguo dictador
fue enterrado aquí en el 2006 el padre
de marwan organizó su traslado
al principio el gobierno iraquí tenía la
intención de enterrar a Sadam hussein
en un lugar secreto en Bagdad
Pero cuando la delegación conducida por
mi padre fue al lugar
[Música]
insistieron en recuperar los restos para
enterrarlo donde él en su propio
territorio
porque sabían que habría muchos
problemas si fuesenterrado en un lugar
secreto en Bagdad en cuanto se llegó a
un acuerdo supieron que grupos armados
tenían la intención de secuestrar El
cadáver durante el traslado por
carretera Entonces
abdubari mi padre habló con los
norteamericanos despidió su autorización
para transportar el cuerpo en uno de sus
aviones respondieron que eran muy
sensible
y que debían obtener la autorización del
más alto nivel del Estado tras una hora
recibieron finalmente la aprobación del
presidente Bush para transportar El
cadáver de Sadam husein en un avión
norteamericano
en su pueblo natal al aulla en estas
fotos transmitidas por antiguos
habitantes el mausoleo construido para
[__] los restos ropa del Antiguo
dictador también está expuesta
y visitantes venían de todo el país para
visitar a la olla
más tarde el gobierno irá aquí quiso
cerrar esta sala
luego tuvo lugar la guerra contra daes
y la sala fue bombardeada durante las
operaciones de liberación de la ciudad
actualmente nadie sabe dónde se
encuentra el cuerpo de San hussein hay
rumores según los cuales las tribus de
la región lo exhumaron antes de la
llegada del daesh y lo enterraron de
nuevo en un lugar secreto en nuestra
visita los palacios de Sadam continúa en
estas ruinas los Soldados del imam son
guías turísticos con un discurso bien
aceitado
Debemos conservar estos palacios para
que se vuelvan testigos de esta terrible
época
frente a nuestra insistencia para
ingresar a la olla nos hacen hablar con
otros responsables
díganles que esperen en la base no
filmaron verdad
Pero al final tenemos la impresión de
que nos engañan a pesar de nuestra
insistencia nadie tomará la
responsabilidad de dejarnos ingresar al
pueblo fantasma
para ahondar un poco en el misterio de
este lugar nos dirigimos a erbil en el
kurdistán iraquí donde una parte de los
antiguos habitantes de la olla está
exiliada
Esta es la casa carriendo
no cuento con el dinero para comprarla
me cuesta 600 dólares mensuales
es duro porque el estado ya no me paga
desde 2015 es cierto llegamos al poder
gracias al partido Bad y a nuestra tribu
la tribunazir aprovechó bastante
pero hoy en día el partido cayó y
nuestra autoridad también
una caída brutal que afecta a toda la
tribu sin excepción la prueba de una
venganza política y no del deseo de
Justicia según este jefe de tribus
saben estas acusaciones de estar con
daesh en realidad no hay una sola tribu
en la región que no tenga uno o dos
miembros que se hayan unido a daege
los nuestros están Muertos o no sabemos
dónde están
seguro no están en el país
siete años desde que estos habitantes
están lejos de su tierra desde que las
milicias chiítas tomaron el control de
su pueblo ninguno de ellos ha podido
regresar ni un día gracias a testimonios
e imágenes satelitales han podido sin
embargo documentar los cambios en el
lugar
Estaba rodeado de granjas
pero ahora todas estas tierras están
secas sabemos que incendiaron granjas Se
observa imágenes satelitales del mismo
lugar de 2014 o 2013 notará que la
tierra estaba verde
pero ahora en el mapa se ve que es un
desierto
y sabemos que después de haber quemado
las tierras las transformaron en granjas
piscícolas para sus tropas que ahora
viven en alaya
[Música]
una información que nos confirmaron
muchas Fuentes e incluso altos
responsables del gobierno
[Música]
en Bagdad nos reunimos con marwan
altabari que sigue haciendo peticiones
ante las autoridades
[Música]
Gracias por recibirnos
representa a todos los jefes tribales de
saladín
me gustaría hacerles una nueva solicitud
al ministro para que los habitantes de
la región puedan regresar a su hogar
nosotros como Ministerio de la
inmigración y de los desplazados debemos
tener autorización de las fuerzas de
seguridad en el lugar para estar seguros
de que no hay ningún peligro actualmente
y que podemos hacer que la gente regrese
según él podría haber represalias contra
su tribu en caso de regreso Lo siento
pero sí hay una obsesión con los
habitantes de alaya y muchos de ellos
temen regresar y nos piden una fuerza
especial para protegerlos actualmente
estamos trabajando su solicitudes para
garantizarles eso y Esperamos que el
regreso pueda tener lugar Próximamente
pero tras siete años de espera esta
posición oficial suena más bien pretexto
para alargar lo más posible el regreso
de estos habitantes desposeídos
cuando usted lo aislan de todas las
tomas de decisiones del país siendo una
comunidad importante de este país Cuando
se es desplazado e impiden El regreso
cuando debe obedecer órdenes injustas
que fueron pensadas y concebidas solo
para castigarlo
entonces usted tendrá la impresión de
haberse vuelto un ciudadano de segunda
clase
y ellos no va a cambiar los unitas y los
chilitas se castigan por un problema que
Data de 1400 años como imaginar que no
seamos castigados por eventos que
tuvieron lugar hace tan solo 20 años
[Música]
Gracias por acompañarnos en esta edición
de boleto de vuelta que en esta
oportunidad nos llevó a Irak visitamos
20 años después de la Segunda Guerra del
Golfo que afectó a millones de personas
recuerde que puede Ingresar a nuestra
página web France 24.com para ver esta
emisión y las anteriores Hasta pronto
[Música]